en este vídeo quiero demostrarte existen
un montón de números irracionales y
además que siempre entre cualesquiera
dos racionales cualesquiera dos
racionales que tú te tomes podemos
encontrar un irracional así que vamos a
verlo primero de una manera visual para
que tú entiendas a qué me refiero
imagínate que aquí tengo una meta
numérica ok
va para acá va para acá ok
e imagínate que yo me tomo dos números
irracionales los números irracionales
que yo quiera se me antoja tomarme este
de aquí va a ser mi racional número uno
ok no voy a tomar otro racional por aquí
este va a ser mi versión al número 2
ok cuáles sean los racionales que yo me
tomen entre ellos siempre va a existir
un irracional siempre va a existir un
irracional y justo eso es lo que quiero
ver en este vídeo que entre cualesquiera
dos racionales existe un irracional y no
forzosamente tiene que estar justo en
este punto puede estar en cualquier
parte entre estos dos racionales
y eso es bastante impresionante porque
fíjate que nosotros sabemos que tenemos
un buen de racionales ahora si nosotros
sabemos que tenemos un buen de
racionales de que tenemos una infinidad
de racionales bueno pues en medio
siempre de cualesquiera todos racionales
podemos encontrar un irracional lo que
quiere decir que hay una infinidad
también de irracionales son un montón
ahora para llegar a la demostración de
justo esto que te estoy contando qué te
parece si empezamos con un intervalo que
conozcamos muy bien me voy a tomar el
intervalo de 0 y 1 es decir 0 nosotros
sabemos que es más chico que 1 bueno
déjame ponerlo por acá aquí voy a poner
a 1
ok y si yo te pregunto si existe algún
irracional entre 0 y 1 seguramente tú me
vas a decir que si lo hay un ejemplo es
uno entre raíz de 21 entre raíz de 2 que
es exactamente lo mismo que raíz de 2
raíz de 2 entre 2 que por cierto es
aproximadamente y bueno es
aproximadamente porque es un número
irracional es aproximadamente 0.7 0 7 10
6 7 8
joe 11 y muchos decimales más recuerda
que como es un racional tiene una
infinidad de decimales pero bueno esto
es lo que es aproximadamente raíz de 2
entre 2 y este número claramente está
entre 0 y 1 así que ya sabemos que
existe al menos 1 y por lo tanto lo voy
a poner aquí raíz de 2 sobre 2 lo mejor
no voy a poner como uno entre raíz d
bueno al menos ya sabemos que en el
intervalo 0 y 1 existe al menos un
irracional que es justo este de aquí
ahora basándome en esto que ya sabemos
en el intervalo 0 aún no voy a construir
un irracional que esté justo entre estos
dos racionales así que para eso quiero
que te des cuenta de algo muy importante
si yo me tomo r2 el racional 2 ya esto
le quito
a esto le quito antes de cambiar de
color le voy a quitar el bastión alumno
el racional 1 bueno pues esto es mayor
que 0
esto es más grande que 0 y nosotros nos
podemos dar cuenta precisamente porque
así no estamos tomando estos dos
racionales estamos diciendo que erre 2
es más grande que era 1 ok pero este de
aquí me va a servir bastante porque
ahora voy a multiplicar todo por justo
esto que está aquí voy a multiplicar la
parte derecha y la parte izquierda por
esta diferencia de racionales que tengo
aquí y por lo tanto me va a quedar am
vamos a ponerlo así 0 o no espera déjame
cambiar de herramienta me va a quedar
que 0
por este de aquí por a r2 menos de rd
uno que lo voy a poner justo por aquí ok
y los voy a poner multiplicando así que
déjenme tomar este color 0 que
multiplica a estos dos ok esto es menor
y sabemos que la desigualdad se conserva
porque tenemos un número positivo y como
tenemos un número positivo las
desigualdades se conservan
esto es menor que a uno entre raíz de 21
entre raíz de 2 ok esto que sube
multiplicar a éste porque recuerda que
voy a multiplicar todo por esto entonces
déjame ponerlo que estamos multiplicando
para esto déjenme agarrar aquí este
color y los voy a pasar multiplicando y
esto a su vez es menor que 11 por estos
de aquí no voy a poner así que 11 x
vamos a ponerlos aquí otra vez por estos
dos de aquí ahora me doy cuenta que es 0
x r 2 - será uno bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que 0 por lo tanto podemos quitar
esto de aquí
déjeme quitarlo lo voy a quitar ok y
solamente quedarnos con 0 esto es 0 y
por otra parte aquí tengo 1 por estos de
aquí así que mejor dejarlo quitar esto
de aquí voy a quitar esto the climb y
solamente voy a poner r 2 - r 1 ok que
es justo lo que nosotros queríamos era
de 2 - r 1 ahora esto ya se va
apareciendo un poco a un número
irracional que esté entre estos dos y si
te das cuenta lo que nos falta es aquí
tener la r2 y aquí tener la r1 así que
qué te parece si sumo a uno de todos los
lados de esta desigualdad voy a sumar a
r 1 aquí aquí también voy a sumar a r 1
y aquí también voy a sumar a r 1 de tal
manera que 0 +0 1 me va a quedar
solamente r 1 me racional 1 que por
cierto me lo tomé de una forma aleatoria
esto es menor que tiene bueno pues aquí
me quedan r 1 r 1
1 entre la raíz de 21 entre la raíz de 2
que sube es multiplicar a r2 menos 0 1
que a su vez multiplica a lo que
tendríamos aquí ok perfecto esto lo voy
a poner aquí y voy a cerrar mi
paréntesis así que déjame a poner esto
de aquí me puede servir un paréntesis y
de este lado del lado derecho me va a
quedar r 2 +
efe 1 - r 1 de tal manera que este y
éste se va y solamente me queda r 2
entonces del lado derecho no queda
solamente r 2 ahora date cuenta de lo
que estoy diciendo estoy diciendo algo
muy importante que entre r 1 es decir
entre este racional que me acabo de
tomar y r2 este racional que me acaba de
tomar estoy construyendo una racional
que está en alguna parte entre ellos dos
ahora lo padre es que r1 y r2 los
tomamos de manera arbitraria son
cualquier par de racionales que tú
quieras y este número de aquí
este número de aquí es un número
irracional
podemos ver eso bueno porque es de 2 - r
1 este es un número racional y recuerda
que un número racional cuando lo
multiplicamos por un número racional
está sabemos que es irracional un
racional por un irracional me da un
número racional así que todo esto de
aquí es un número irracional y si a esto
le sumamos un número racional llegamos a
un número irracional justo en los vídeos
pasados hemos probado que cuando
nosotros sumamos un racional con una
irracional me da un irracional y cuando
nosotros multiplicamos un irracional por
un racional me da también un irracional
así que esto de aquí es irracional
irracional que es justo lo que yo quería
llegar a aquí en el intervalo entre r1 y
r2 exista al menos un irracional que es
este de aquí